alors comment les ukrainiens après anti
les dernières annonces venues de moscou
at-il vraiment les déclarations russes
sont les écoute
il ya un proverbe houle connaissez
peut-être promettent de se marier et se
marier en réalité sont deux choses
différentes
du côté du pays agresseur il ya déjà eu
des accords non respectés
c'est pourquoi il ne serait ni
intelligent ni sage d'y croire
pleinement
je suis craignait et je veux que tout
soit ukrainien ici je veux que l'ukraine
soit protégé de poutine
comment est ce possible qu'aujourd'hui
dans ce siècle nous soyons menacés par
la russie
gulliver craag bonjour on vous
retrouvera kiev on l'a entendu les
ukrainiens reste très prudent
oui il accueille cette nouvelle d'un
retrait possible des troupes russes avec
le plus grand scepticisme je pense que
le ministre des affaires étrangères a
commis trop cool et bat parle pour
l'opinion dominante quand il dit la
russie dit beaucoup de choses on croira
quand on le verra qu'on se sera
démontrée compte il y aura des rapports
des renseignements de l'otan ou encore
des états unis où les ukrainiens eux
mêmes confirmant qu effectivement ces
forces ont quitté les endroits près des
frontières ukrainienne et se sont
retournés vers leur base plus loin en
russie comme le ministre russe des
affaires de la défense l'a annoncé et
ils ont bien raison de douter un peu de
la parole des russes puisque les russes
ont à maintes fois annoncée du retrait
des troupes son procédé un réel retrait
c'était déjà le cas au printemps 2000 21
où ils ont annoncé un retrait massif est
en réalité seulement une partie assez
peu importe en réalité des forces qui
étaient amassés aux frontières
ukrainiens alors n'est rentré à ses
bases permanentes et encore en décembre
la russie avait annoncé le retrait de 10
mille troupe est en réalité ce mois-là
selon les renseignements ukrainiens
c'est plus de 40000 troupes
supplémentaires qui sont arrivés dans
des zones près de la frontière
ukrainienne
gulliver la diplomatie et est toujours à
l'oeuvre hier
olaf scholz était chez vous à kiev
aujourd'hui il est reçu à moscou il
tient d'ailleurs une conférence de
presse en ce moment avec vladimir
poutine est ce que les ukrainiens compte
sur cette énième efforts diplomatiques
du leader
alors de mettre couler bas tout en étant
aussi skeptic sur le retrait des troupes
a toutefois dit qu il pensait que le
crâne et ses partenaires occidentaux
avaient peut-être réussi à éviter pour
le moment une escalade russe du moins
personne en ukraine en tout cas non
excusez moi c'est plutôt les officiels
le président ukrainien qui ne pense pas
que l'invasion c'est pour demain comme
les américains et les reportages dont
certains médias l'ont dit donc il ya un
minimum d'optimisme louis sur au moins
la possibilité de continuer les
pourparlers on a vu au late show hier à
kiev aux côtés de volodymyr zelensky il
a dit qu'il allait apporter le message à
vladimir poutine que il est un peu
étrange de discuter de cette possible
entrée de l'ukraine dans l'otan quand
cette idée n'est pas du tout à l'ordre
du jour de l'alliance en ce moment et le
président ukrainien volodimir zelensky
mettre un petit peu d'eau dans son vin
je pense quand on lui a posé la question
de cette accession éventuelle de
l'ukraine à l'otan il a dit l'ukraine ne
renonce absolument pas à cette ambition
mais il a utilisé en ukrainien le
conditionnel nous aimerions entrer dans
l'otan il a parlé de cette entrée comme
aussi d'un rêve et il a souligné que à
la fin cela ne dépendait pas uniquement
des ukrainiens mais bien sûr des autres
pays membres de l'alliance
merci beaucoup gulliver crack depuis
kiev pour ces éléments